So, it's pretty straight forward to think
about applying the negative sign to both
the x and the 9 when we're talking abut
subtracting expressions from one another,
but what we're really doing here is using
an example of a much broader property. And
that property is the Distributive
Property. So, we're distributing this
negative sign to both the x and to the 9
when we say that we want to subtract them
both from the 4. So, I'm going to show you
a slightly different way of looking at how
to distribute that negative sign and what
distributing a negative sign really means.
First things first, we know that when we
subtract, like we're doing here, that's
actually the same as adding the negative
of the thing that you want to subtract.
So, for example, if we have 5-3, that's
actually equal to 5 plus -3. Now, that may
seem like we're working backwards but hang
in there, this is going to be helpful. So,
let's do the same thing here. This is
equal to 4 plus the negative of this
entire quantity. However, when we're
taking the negative of something, what
we're really doing is multiplying it by
-1. So, in order to get -3, we actually
have to say -1 times +3. So, that means
that if we want -x+9, we actually need
-1 times x+9.
You'll notice that I didn't write a
multiplication sign between this
coefficient, -1, and the parentheses
that's around x+9, because remember,
there's an invisible multiplication sign
implied between those when there's no
space between them. So, I'll just get rid
of that. So here, it's a bit easier to see
explicitly why the Distributive Property
is being applied in this case. We have a
-1 that we're multiplying each term inside
the parenthesis by. So, both x and -9 are
each being multiplied by -1. The
Distributive Property basically says that
if you have some number or variable, let's
call it a, and you want to multiply that
by some number of terms that are inside
parentheses, let's just pick two to be
simple and call them b and c. And we'll
just add them, although of course, c can
be negative, and you could be subtracting
or b could be negative. If you want to get
rid of the parentheses, you'll end up with
a being multiplied by each of these terms. So,
the a multiplies the b and that's added to
a times c as well. So, you can see why we
use the word distribute here. The
multiplication of the a affects the b and
also affects the c. So, you have a times b,
original operator that was between b and
c, the plus sign, a times c.
So, if we use that property in this case,
we leave our 4+ and then we have -1 times x.
Write the sign that's between the two
terms inside the parentheses, -1 times 9.
However, we know that -1 times x is just -x and
-1 times 9 is also just -9, so we end up with
4-x-9. And that is actually what's happening
when we are quote-unquote distributing this
minus sign to both terms in here and then,
of course, we could rearrange and simplify
again.